listen y'all always want to say how bad
America is listen Europe you're not any
better
I asked black soccer players how they
feel football players if you get hurt
when they play in Italy or in Spain or
even in England sometimes how they enjoy
having bananas thrown at them how they
like seeing the salutes of our favourite
mustache man all throughout the state of
former pinna or how they like monkey
chats when they play in greece brother
we're not talking about one or two
people we're talking about a whole
section thousands of people screaming
the stuff at the player as the players
they're crying they're excited they're
happy and we're still this type of
behavior is common in the Italian
championship throwing bananas monkey
chants a phenomenon that doesn't even
surprise the fans anymore like here at
the let's see-oh stadium that's how it
works here sometimes we hear things but
really it's not sysm come on it's just
teasing with the players they're just
football jokes is nothing more breath
try doing that in the United States you
have a small incident and it becomes
national news over there it's so
commonplace it barely gets the same
coverage we just reported sometimes so
they didn't report it sometimes because
that what they do nothing about it
incidents happen here in hockey leagues
you're oculus when there is one black
player and he's getting and it makes the
news and their actions that are taking
yeah over there it's just a Tuesday
night I'm just using sports as an
example because it happens on a very
public platform in front of TVs and you
see how little people care nobody nobody
cares nobody can and it happens all the
time it happens all the time all the
time and so I bring that up because I'm
using that as a lens into how bad it
gets on a day to day basis for a lot of
people I mean look at Italy the problems
they're having with black folks over
there very extensive and well documented
and it happens in a lot of different
other countries and I'm talking about
very severe I mean even in Greece
there's been a number of stories of
people on the basis of their skin taking
big meetings now some people say those
weren't Greeks there were foreign
nationals I'm just giving you guys
examples but throughout the content on
your is a very vast continent with
different forms of culture and so I'm
using this as a
example but I understand this is
segmented into a couple countries not
every country within Europe is including
this but from my general experience it
just seems interesting to me that all
the comments are made about America when
within Europe there are a lot of
countries where things are really bad
yeah listen I'm just about my personal
experience the women I've talked to who
used to live in those countries in world
moved here or like Braille it's night
and day I didn't feel comfortable taking
the metro at night in some cities I
didn't feel comfortable walking home at
night in some cities like it was given
that I was going to be harassed and
bothered
whereas here in a lot of other places
they feel much safer both of the girls
that it comes from a shoulder knee
giving one shot from friends and we have
conversations oh oh you've been here a
couple of months stay here yeah cool so
what you liked what did you notice about
here that's different from there she's
like mm I can wear a skirt and no no
that's it I walk outside and I can wear
skirts and nobody cares I've even had a
girl that worked for us work with us
whatever got a different gig she was
from a part of Paris and she had rocks
thrown at her because she didn't respond
to advance of the end it would happen
often
was a cop it's a city in the suburbs in
the left once man once I realized that
the women weren't reacting that crazy to
me and made me realize oh this is
cultural for them they were just picking
yeah me budget yo listen things I've
heard yeah they fit that they woman yeah
I would never dream of saying to someone
I hate yeah and it messed me up you want
annoyed because I always had this idea
that Europe is super progressive in
reality they're very socially
conservative super socially conservative
18-hundreds rough it blew me away
yeah my whole perception got shattered
I'm like wait these are the people
lecturing the world you guys the same
ones that are saying like yeah you know
what by one tenth of vaccines
while this is on Africa why over here
they having problems with
and when that story broke about those
doctors saying hey why don't we test the
vaccines for this pandemic out in Africa
and everyone was shocked I looked at
where they were from and I like France
I'm like sounds about right
you have to understand also France as a
country has to this day still been
taking reparations from yeah 13 or 14
countries in Africa who have all their
money set up in French banks and they
cannot get it up basically tied up a
whole bunch of African economies in
France they've made it so that if any
resources are discovered in these
African countries that France has to be
the first buyer they've made it so that
if these countries want to buy weapons
for the military France has to be the
seller they have crippled a lot of
economies and made them type you know I
feel like a lot of incidents I deal with
here when you're relating to race I feel
like a lot of it's very subtle generally
speaking what I deal with it more in
North America whereas over there just
over it in your face yeah well thank you
yeah you know so pop you some pretty
powerful you make you a superb silent
quasi see yeah they always look at you
like daters it's crazy
Dave you gave me the option between
living in the States of living there I
would live in the States pretty much
every time that's me person I understand
why people wouldn't there's a lot of
reasons not to do it but I preferred it
there maybe you feel different but the
stuff that I've seen like that football
chance that they blew me away throwing
bananas at players nobody fish you know
what a lot of people do denounce it but
my problem is more so like at the
systemic level we're the owners of the
clubs don't do anything in the league
doesn't take any really sizable action
and it was like how how could you guys
and I'm just like they never do it cuz
they don't give it so anyways I just
made this so you guys could have a
little bit of context but listen next
time you guys are hearing any of this
nonsense from many European I'm back bro
look at your own country look to your
neighbors countries if it's not your
country some of them are really bad
trust me we get a lot of European
immigrants here and just me that they
have to make well they're like guys
don't bother me when I'm at a cafe they
just leave me alone or I can walk around
and it took me a time to adjust that
like oh I was living
in a weird environment I was like a girl
I know I went to environment it was
really weird for me too the skirt
comment was not just from one girl it
was so many girl if either I can work
skirts or shorts or I can just walk in
the sheets rough just before this we
just Skype call with homegirl yeah and
for frase and she said I would never
think of wearing a skirt or anything
just short work my legs would be seen in
Paris at night and here
that's just summer winter for some girls
who really like club for some girls who
like I'll take the cold seems club
lineups for girls like that in winter in
minus 30 divided 33 for justice
no Brunei and a skirt you know what a
Pecos I'm like I'm girlish of you brave
or you done but I guess you just really
wanna dance sort of late who did you say
Lewis you see yeah did you hear the
comments about you up the chair thing is
that me it was growing up it was here
cuz I used to go to college I was French
hmm and so ninety percent of the
teachers were French for French from
France different regions of France and
it was that and I was like one of the
only black person set out to cross the
south shore of Montreal as a garbage to
I growing up and was that as well the
comments the looks the way if subtle
because they're here but yeah they used
to be pretty freakin bad you want to
talk about colonial mindset house I went
to French school I wanted to say when I
was living me see all my teachers were
French you know what my dislike from the
for the French language came from that
school my teachers they would look down
on us so much of course I remember being
in like fifth grade and I would go to
school and I would be terrified to speak
French because of the way that they
would belittle us when we made mistakes
and that's carried on into my adult
years because of the way that they
looked any like I was subhuman the way
that they talked to me with their Eric
right it means my relationship with the
French language train because the way I
interpret it was like Oh
French hurts me so I'm not going to
speak French and I'm not going to like
French I'm going to make any excuse I
can to dislike the language that was the
relationship I built with that language
because of them I still remember my
teacher man and he was so bad he was
like but are you stupid
are you an idiot and to hear that from
an adult when you're 13 Pruss I was a
kid kid I'm an elementary school I was a
regular they were bad bad it was crazy
that's cool and I spoke to that school
about I don't remember who but someone's
like yeah I'm not as old as you are
but my sibling weather that's cool not
so long ago and was pretty much the same
so saying it's like yo they just
belittle you and it's just I mean it's
not surprising French people are not
necessarily known for being heartwarming
and warm and welcoming it kind that's
never been what people used to define
French people so at first glance it's
very easy to dislike me and I definitely
dislike them you see it in the cartoons
Pepe Le Pew that's a depiction of what a
French they don't smell very good
because the items not great and the way
teach you women they're very aggressive
not really say that about the hygiene
that's pretty rude I don't give a [ __ ]
that's what it is that's a stereotype
you see a bunch about soul and I'm very
comfortable there was a stat that read
that a lot of them don't take showers
that's what I said you told me that I
remember and I went to look it up online
and it was a crazy said like a lot of
them don't take showers I understand
liking bleu cheese but smelling like it
you know I mean I don't know if that's
necessarily the best truth it's like
saying French people don't tip but it's
true no they don't think we know gives
we live here and there's a lot of them
and it's just a cultural thing because
their country they don't tip there but
when they come because if you go to
Europe you'll see this when you go to
Europe it's in some places it's actually
root to tip yeah but now that people
reject my money but they come here and
they don't say knowing that they'd
should tip no
thank you we made the broth about Mack
yeah this was starting about Europe but
really just ended with us hitting on
France because that's what we deal with
here so it's not all of them it's not
all of Europe if not all the people but
there's a lot of you that ruined it for
everybody let's just be clear about that
yeah I just think this kind of stuff is
interesting because there's a perception
of what they're like and the reality is
sometimes very different and you won't
know unless you go there if you spend
time with there or you really know that
people from there but they'll back me up
on a lot of this stuff I'm saying mm-hmm
and if you disagree leave the comments
below but I don't think I'm wrong about
this my general experience of what I've
seen tells me I'm not wrong about this
I've sat down at dinner tables family
dinner tables with people who are French
it is very awkward to hear some of the
stuff that they could say between you
two this couple said I might talk about
that yeah really
absolutely when there's people around I
don't care what you do in the privacy of
your own home whatever whatnot but
you're so open about it
to talk down to your partner in front of
people me I'm not really down with that
so anyways we just want to make this
video to shed light on something but
maybe you guys have a different
experience or maybe you guys want to
share information on why things are the
way that they are this is not to say
that these people are inherently bad or
that their cultures are bad but there
are some elements that are very
questionable if you point fingers at the
u.s. like my father said remember when
I'm when you point your finger at
someone there's always three fingers
that are pointing back at you say it in
your father's tone a loss yeah - so what
you some point D so I'll just write wise
man I wanted to hear this voice doesn't
it sound better
yeah my dad's a poet I like that it is
what it is not to hate on everybody but
whenever you point someone you're not
necessarily better Lisa G I don't wanna
even focus only on a bar people the
comments are gonna want subtitles you're
not getting that
[Music]
you